greetings everyone and hope you're doing
well these days
this talk is to be a quick overview of
agilent's triple quadrupole lcms
portfolio
as the product manager for this
portfolio i'd like to show you
some of my favorite highlights and
things i'd like to point out
although agilent has been involved in
the mass spectrometry field for a long
time
in regards to gcms you'd be surprised to
find out that our first triple quadruple
lcms launch
was in 2006 with the g6410
this was then followed up in the
proceeding years
with the launch of other models within
that decade such as the 6420 which is
not shown
but the 6430 and the 6460.
a major breakthrough was made at the
start of the decade by adding an
innovative new component which is the
dual
stacked ring ion funnel and this feature
dramatically pushed instrument detection
limits
lower and lower additionally instead of
a linear design
the 90 degree turn in the ion optics
rail
was included as a way to reduce noise
from the fragmentation process
as we move into the 20 teens two related
models to the 6490 were launched
expanding on its capability which is the
6495a
with an extended mass range and also by
creating a version of this instrument
without an ifunnel resulting in an
incredible workhorse instrument
we call the 6470a many of which are
still used today
in addition to the launch of a 6495b
model and not shown but launched in 2017
2017 and 2018 brought along a new era of
mass spectrometer instrumentation
with the triple quadrupole lcms this was
a disruptively miniaturized platform
with onboard instrument intelligence and
diagnostics
and based on the hardware inside we were
able to retain the performance
of the 6460 within this box
last year at asms we launched the 6495c
with a completely redesigned ifunnel
drastically improving
measurement precision and performance
for methods containing hundreds of mrams
within the method
additionally we've added vac shield as
it was a popular feature for multivo
that allowed users to carry out
maintenance quickly and easily
lastly this year at asms 2020
for the asms 2020 reboot event
we're launching an updated version of
the highly popular workhorse instrument
the 6470b this retains many of the
performance
characteristics of the 6470a but updated
for today's
problems with the addition of that
shield
so as we move along into the future
ultimately our aim is to enable
our users to do good science driving us
to develop new features
technologies and workflows to keep up
with customers ever-evolving needs
so before i go over the current triple
quadruple lcms portfolio in hardware
details
i'm happy to announce that for the asms
2020 reboot
we're launching a new instrument called
the 6470b
triple quadruple lcms system the 6470b
triple quadruple lcms is the latest
version of our trusted workhorse
on the 6470 platform
leveraging much of the technology that
made this platform successful
you can expect the 6470b to be just as
trusted
rugged and versatile with the added
enhancement of vaxshield to maximize
instrument uptime
and improve ease of maintenance
with that agilent's triple quadrupole
lcms portfolio
contains only three base products
the first product is the eltivo which
was designed to be a routine workhorse
instrument
focusing on ease of use instrument
intelligence
and serviceability in addition to its
most distinguishing feature
its size and form factor
next up is the 6495c triple quadruple
lcms
our ultra high performance instrument
built to tackle the most demanding
routine and research applications
each technological component has been
built to extract the greatest number of
ions
for advanced applications without
complicating the instrument control
this allows researchers to focus on
scientific inquiries
rather than instrumentation problems
and last but definitely not least
sandwiched between the two models
is the 6470 triple quadrupole lcms
our most popular lcms triple quadrupole
to date
as it provides the ruggedness robustness
and ease of use from the ultivo while
maintaining many
of the research enabled characteristics
of the 6495c
each instrument was built to focus on
solving different
aspects of customer problems while
maintaining
consistency and cohesiveness throughout
when jumping from instrument to
instrument within our portfolio
we've put a lot of effort so users can
feel confident
that they know how to run each
instrument they're operating with the
same familiarity
yet there's a distinct and incomparable
uniqueness
each model provides
an important and distinguishing feature
of agilent's triple quadrupole lcms
portfolio
is the fact that all three instruments
in our current lineup
are vac shield enabled this unified
feature allows users to perform common
usage-based ion-injector capillary
maintenance quickly and efficiently
with minimal downtime this feature works
by allowing the user to remove the ion
injector capillary
without venting the system as the
capillary is drawn out
a ceiling mechanism is automatically
triggered maintaining the instrument's
optimal high vac pressure
and what's unique about this mechanism
is the introduction of an intentional
leak
as if the capillary were in place this
design
prevents back flushing of oil and
contaminants prevents turbulent gas
events
from influencing the instrument's
equilibrated temperatures
to really point out the implications of
this feature users who
implement ion injector capillary
cleaning in their routine maintenance
often expect to spend about
six hours or more to do so this is
because they normally have to allow the
instrument to cool down
properly break vacuum carry out their
maintenance
then re-equilibrate the system again
before carrying out
a new check tune or auto-tune
instead users can simply slide out the
ion injector capillary
do the required maintenance then check
tune or auto tune immediately after
this takes about 30 minutes to an hour
and sometimes even faster with ultivo
and since users no longer have to wait
a number of hours to pump down and
re-equilibrate the system
they can expect to be done in a very
short amount of time
for a little bit of history vac shield
was first pioneered on ultivo
added in 2019 to the 6495c
and now in 2020 with the launch of the
6470b
another common feature shared throughout
the triple quadrupole lcms portfolio
is the use of agilent jet stream
ionization
or ajs for short as the default ion
source configuration for users
we chose this because it provides users
a brighter ion response
due to the application of superheated
nitrogen sheath gas
and a nozzle voltage controller to have
greater influence
over the spray shape and the ion
sampling regions
to really demonstrate the effect of
superheated nitrogen gas
on ion sampling the image shown is
running in standard electrospray
conditions
after sheath gas superheating is enabled
the spray cone is much more focused
and less visible implying that more
liquid droplets have been desolvated
bringing more ions into the mass
spectrometer
because more ions have been desolvated
into the gas
phase greater ion flux is observed
resulting in greater analytical
sensitivity
and allowing customers to achieve lower
limits of detection
than standard esi
however regardless of the applications
users wish to perform
we have a nice portfolio of available
ion sources to utilize
based on the electrospray mechanism or
based on the apci mechanism in addition
to
the ion source interfaces for capillary
electrophoresis
or nano flow hplc
as we go into the actual guts of the
instrument one surprising thing to note
is that the 6470b and the 6495c triple
quadruple lcms systems
are built upon a common ion optics
platform
this means that they share many
performance characteristics to one
another
especially in terms of signal stability
robustness versatility
for different routine and research
applications and the technical capacity
to get the job done
on this common ion optics platform it's
comprised of an octopus ion guide
to allow transmission of ions over a
wide effective m over z range
and rf only brew breaker pre-filter for
the pre-focusing of ions into the quad
defeating the fringe field effects for
higher analytical sensitivity
of course we utilize hyperbolic quads
for efficient
mass selection they're also heated to
maintain
signal stability and prevent mass
calibration errors
a hexapole collision cell which also has
an extended mass transmission range
but is curved and tapered so that we can
prevent neutrals
that are produced after collision from
hitting the detector
while the taper helps refocus and
collimate the ions
for transmission into ms2
and lastly an advanced detector system
comprised of an adjustable
up to 20 kv high energy dinode system
used to launch particles towards an
electron multiplier horn
over the past decade since we have
launched the first
instrument models on this platform we've
iterated and
improved year-over-year to provide the
most reliable
and sensitive lcms systems to our users
one of the nice things we found with
this inoptics platform
on the 6470b and 6495c
is that users really appreciate the
ability to analyze ions
over an extremely wide m over z range
not only could users analyze and
quantitate the bread and butter small
molecules like pesticides
metabolites pharmaceuticals it's also
possible to analyze larger ions such as
peptides oligonucleotides carbohydrates
and synthetic polymers the example shown
here is just a demonstration
of our esil calibration ions throughout
the mass range
showing good performance throughout
additionally we always talk about the
robustness and stability of this ion
optics rail for these instruments
so here's some data to prove it this was
carried out
using our rapid fire system for sample
delivery and in this case
we've carried out 10 000 injections of
pharmaceuticals
spiked into pork plasma this is done
non-stop with no
cleaning or tuning when plotting the
chromatographic peak ratios with their
isotopically labeled standards
signal percent rsds were less than 10
percent
this demonstration was carried out on
the 6470a version of this model
however the iron optics rail was was
retained
with what we have today
so between the 6470 and the 6495
what's different i mentioned earlier
that the ion optics rail is shared
between these two instruments
but notice the protruding area after the
ion source
this houses what's called and what we
refer to as the eye funnel
made up of two stacked ring ion guides
this allows users to excel in the most
rigorous analytical conditions
by achieving incredibly low limits of
detection
and instrument detection limits this
allows users to obtain high measure
print precision
at standard concentrations for greater
detection confidence
this instrument is able to achieve the
lowest levels of analytical sensitivity
because we've extensively considered
what happens
as ions are introduced into the mass
spectrometer
as droplets get desolvated ions entered
the instrument as a diffuse cloud
influenced by electronic forces to
capture as much of the ion cloud as
possible
the first stage of the ion funnel
captures stray ions
and collimates it back into the beam the
second stage
further focuses the ion beam for
transfer to the ion guide
i mean the end result is a greater
number of ions flowing into the
instrument
as a demonstration consider a standard
checkout experiment
one picogram over serpentine column the
chromatographic peak shape is very nice
signal is confidently detected but it
essentially tells us nothing of the
analytical sensitivity of the instrument
because we can't see the noise
instead one femtogram of recipient on
column is injected
which is a thousand times less giving us
a better sense of the
baseline noise and the rough magnitude
of concentration levels
users can expect to successfully detect
without issue
one interesting thing is that to
guarantee the analytical sensitivity and
performance of this instrument
this exact experiment is demonstrated at
every customer installation
where we expect to observe and measure
an instrument detection limit value of
less than 0.65
phenograms of a serpentine on column and
this is specified as the best idl
specification on the market
the last triple quadruple lcms hardware
platform in our portfolio
is the altivo triple quadruple lcms
which was a disruptive product to the
industry
many of the hardware components were
re-engineered
to ensure that it had a small form
factor
however despite its size the performance
of this
instrument is uncompromising as it was
intended to be a continuation
of the legacy workhorse instrument the
6460
with the same specifications instrument
sensitivity
and robustness with any improvements
that we can fit in
horizontally the altivo is roughly three
times smaller than the 6460
giving users access to precious lab
space for other tasks
like sample staging or for even fitting
more instruments into a smaller space
additionally the eltivo was designed to
be stackable
by seamlessly incorporating into the
hplc stack
at the base and when incorporated
with the right furniture such as the
flexbench ms
the altivo is completely unified as a
mobile platform
this allows some users to bring in and
out a mass spectrometer
whenever it's needed
oftentimes people equate small to less
sensitive or incapable
so in order to preserve instrument
sensitivity
many of the traditional mass
spectrometer components
had to be reconsidered and redesigned to
operate in a small form factor
the altivo was such an incredible
advancement forward for the development
of this small
form factor due to the large number of
inventions and innovations made
routine maintenance had to be simple so
the vac shield was first developed on
this platform
a traditional octopus ion guide is too
large
so instead the cyclone ion guide a
twisted and tapered
hexadodecopol was invented
the traditional two centimeter rf only
brewbaker pre-filters
are too large so instead one millimeter
dc only virtual pre and post filters
were developed instead
the quadrupoles had to be shrunk which
is a major manufacturing challenge on
its own
and lastly the vortex collision cell was
based on the cyclone ion guide design
to maximize iron recollection after
fragmentation
and to prevent sensitivity loss within
this small form factor
with many of these hardware innovations
included on this platform
we were recognized in 2018 as award
winners by ibo
and scientist choice
as we do so with all our instruments a
robustness test was carried out on
ultivo as well
in this case 10 000 non-stop
uninterrupted injections of pesticides
spiked in black tea
were measured surprisingly despite how
dirty the original sample was
and how dirty the source got peak area
percent rsd remained less than 10
percent
demonstrating the instrument's
incredible robustness
for routine analysis samples
and as we pushed the instrument hardware
boundaries
the instrument control software did as
well
incorporated with ultivo or software
features designed
to address many of the pains users
experienced
when interfacing with the instrument
things like knowing when to carry out
instrument maintenance
routine or extensive or having the
instrument
check tuned or auto-tuned and ready to
go once users come into the lab
additionally data analysis should be
comprehensive
but not complicated or complex
throughout our
whole portfolio with our data analysis
platform
we have allowed users to hone in on the
features that matter to them the most
streamlining their workflows to be as
efficient as possible
and lastly even with only three triple
quadruple lcms products within our
portfolio
the amount of hardware innovations
features and functions
is a lot to take in instead you can rely
on
agilent to be a partner for your success
as we also
aid in solving user problems through our
end-to-end
comprehensive workflow solutions these
kits contain all the necessary materials
needed
for a successful workflow for example
this comprehensive vet drug workflow
solution we've just launched
contains everything users need to get
started
in vet drug analysis on a 6470b
or a 6495c for the analysis
of over 200 compounds
before i wrap up i just want to point
out the guiding principles
and the approach that we take when
designing our mass spectrometers
we don't want the mass spectrometer to
be just a box
but rather a component for users overall
laboratory success
so as we move into the future we're
always keeping the user's needs in mind
so as i close i just want to wrap up and
remind you
that agilent has a rounded three product
triple quadruple lcms portfolio
with the latest launch this asms reboot
for the 6470b
we strive to provide users with
instruments that are not only
sensitive but extremely robust as well
the software we provide aims to be
comprehensive
but not complicated or complex this
error requires software to be
matched with their hardware for better
instrument
intelligence and monitoring
sometimes focusing just on
instrumentation
is a lot to take in on its own not
considering sample prep
method development consumable choice etc
so we provide lcms oriented
comprehensive
workflow solutions such as the vet drug
analysis
solution
and lastly we're always sticking our ear
to the ground
regarding user feedback because we want
future development to be driven
by addressing real user pain points and
needs
and keeping up with their ever-evolving
and changing
requirements with that i'd like to thank
you for listening
and if you're interested in any of these
solutions please check out agilent.com